Last week uh we were reflecting upon this idea of tailbears
uh and gossip and people that spread rumors about you
and people that don't check uh messages what we call uh we
called
supposition
uh rumors we differentiated between gossiping and slander
and
we talked about this idea of fisk.
What is
fisk?
Anybody that paid attention, what's
Fisk?
You guys know there's no way.
You guys are just shy.
Inshallah. What's
Fisk?
Huh?
What's
Fisk?
Nobody going once.
Is it related to?
Yeah, it is.
So, what's a
fascinating sins? They openly transgress.
So
spreading anything that you know that you hear about somebody else without checking it or verifying
it
is uh open
transgression and that's why the imam here begins with
follows this up with the defending the reputation of your brother or sister that if you
want to engage in fraternity or friendship with your brother with your sister with your friend
with your community members it's up to you to def it's upon you to defend their
reputation to make sure Their reputation is good.
The word for reputation in
is
can everybody
say
it comes from the word which means to hear.
It's what is heard about that other person
which is related to
reputation. And I im
says
it is from amongst the signs of someone who is honest in fellowship with his fellow
that he accepts his defects, compliments his deficiencies and forgives his lapses.
So if you're in any relationship, you have to recognize that the expectation is that person
is going to have deficiencies.
That person will have
deficiencies. There are some lapses that they have.
And
imm
says
that
none of you
uh will be able to or are able to recognize a deficiency in your brother in
your sister except
that you know that it's in yourself.
It takes one to
no one. So you only recognize that thing
because it's in yourself.
Now one of the things the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says about Muslims
he
said
that the believer is
um gullible. They're very innocent when it comes to people's defects
and they're generous.
So if somebody comes to you
and they ask you for something, you know, brother comes, you go to the you go
to the movies with your friends and there's that one guy that always forgets his wallet.
Always forgets his wallet.
Every month you have your monthly movie meet up.
Halal movie of course.
And
they
he always forgets his wallet.
And everybody else knows like bro like this dude watch.
He's going to forget his wallet.
And they be like, "Bro, why don't you bring your wallet next time?
You know what?
You could sell me."
But this one other brother in there, he's always like, "Yeah, man.
Take it. No, you're good.
You're good. Whatever."
And he doesn't realize like, "Man, man, this guy's really going through something."
Every month, that one day on Friday, subhan Allah, somehow he forgets his wallet.
That gullibility of that believer is part of their fra.
It's a good thing.
That's a good thing.
And the one that is
the one that is
uh a
transgressor is somebody who their first thing is that they're uh they'll begin to
be lin
they're uh
um
they're abusive to somebody else.
They won't they'll be stingy.
They're tightfisted. They have a bad opinion.
They degrade the other person.
is more is like they're degrading, dismissive of that person cuz they're like, "Oh, if I
give it to them, here are all the bad things they're going to do with it."
So, somebody comes to you, you know, somebody knocks on your window by the highway, sure
this has happened to you before, and somebody comes asking for money, they have those posters,
Allah,
protect our
from homelessness and inability.
um
that they asked for something the because of the society that's raised us to have a
bad opinion. We think what
they're probably going to get something vice related to it.
They're going to do this with the they don't have a job.
Whatever a believer that's in
tune with their fit, they just give whatever they have.
I'll give you this much.
There is easy for them.
Right?
And I would relate to you before continuing to the next of this imali.
Do you guys know who I imali
is?
Anybody know? Raise your hand.
You know I imali.
You've heard of this.
Few of you.
Good. Alhamdulillah. If you don't know, Google Immuzali.
Write it down in your notebook.
Immali.
And read something about him.
He's known as
Islam, the proof of Islam.
Uh
because of a book that he had written called the
revival of the Islamic spirits uh
sciences.
And the say that if you were to burn every book of Islamic studies and that
was the only one that survived, it would suffice.
Okay? And he was a great scholar, legal
theory.
When he was young, his mother had given him gold to travel with.
He's going from point A to point B.
And he gave him
gold.
And he hid they hid the gold under the
jacket
and he had books with him.
And a group of thieves came and they held him up.
And as they held him up, they said, "What do you have?"
And he said, "My mother," his mother told him advice.
He said, "I have one advice for
you.
Speak the truth even if it's against yourself or it's bitter."
So
he asked, "Do you have anything?"
And as gullible as he was, he has, "I have gold in my pocket."
And my he said, "Why would you tell us that?"
My mother always said, "Speak the truth even if it's of my if it's against myself."
They stole the gold.
And then they saw these books,
these this uh
this this pile of
books,
and they said, "We're going to take that, too."
And he said, "No, no, don't take my books.
Take the gold.
Don't take my books."
Then they were all laughing like you have gold.
Why do you care about these books?
Then they call the chief of the thieves and they say
uh
this guy
he has these books and he has gold but he's more concerned for his books than
his gold.
And they offer he says what's wrong with you?
He's like no see these books they're invaluable to me.
And as he's saying it one of the other thieves offer
the chief thief
coffee.
He's stealing.
Is it halal to steal?
It's one of the It's one of the major sins to steal.
And the thief
says,
"Don't give me the coffee.
I'm
fasting." He's fasting, but he's stealing.
He's fasting, but he's
stealing. And
uh I imali is
confused. I gazali is confused.
And he was like, "What?
He's fasting and stealing."
He makes nothing of it.
And he says, "Oh sir, oh kind sir, please leave.
take my gold just don't take my books indeed they're valuable to me he said how
can something be so valuable to you and I can take it so easily so he
takes his books
and he burns his books in front of him so after that day I imali starts
to memorize all his text from that day on
years later when he's writing the
he's in his 50s he goes to
Hajj
30 years ago 30 years later how many of years and he sees this man he's
doing and he sees this man on the golden door of the cabba and he's crying
crying and he's weeping, asking Allah's forgiveness.
He's asking Allah's whatever.
And he comes closer.
Every single
he comes closer.
He's like, "Wait a minute.
I know this guy."
Like he's the guy that stole these books from me.
And he
taps on his shoulder.
He says, "Hey,
remember that time you stole these books from me?"
And he's like, "What are you doing here?
Like you spend your life thieving.
What's your what are you doing here?"
He says,
"I
used to spend my life doing this haram, that haram, and I used to steal things
from people, but I kept one sunnah alive, and that was a sunnah of fasting.
And because I didn't cut myself from the rope of fasting, Allah has pulled me with
his rope to his
door."
And then he realized and he says these famous
words,
Allah has spoken to me through his tongue.
So there's this
uh
um
idea
of
of of
recognizing that like the um itself
has to have the believers who are good, they have these they have these vulnerable tendencies.
Now if something happens to you twice and thrice over
the prophetam also says to balance cuz our religion is a religion of balance.
A believer doesn't get bit by the same snake hole twice.
It's a hadith.
A believer does not get bit by the same snake hole twice.
So just because you are gullible if something happens to you once once twice thrice you
have to actually you have to take care of yourself.
You can't just trust everybody you know willy-nilly.
They have to earn your trust.
So the base for every believer is that they have a good opinion of their brother
or sister and then uh it either goes it it goes on a deficit or it
enters a positive.
Now
this is slid.
So if you guys have any questions you can put it on the slido.
Um this chapter is called good counsel.
good counsel
where
the Imam here says that from
um
religion is have is is
giving
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
that religion is good
counsel
and imi
says that this is one of the hadith that encompass all of Islam
And the companions
ask
to who who do I give counsel?
He
says
that good counsel is for Allah
um his book,
his prophet, his messenger and for the leaders of the Muslims
Muslim community, the entire Muslim community.
Um,
the word,
you've heard the word
before.
Who's heard the word before?
You've all heard it, right, brother?
I'm giving you.
Generally, it's translated to what?
Huh?
Advice.
I'm going to
I'm going to uh
um
I'm I'm going to give you advice on
something.
Now
the
uh
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says
that the right of all of a Muslim
is to have tawa in Allah
and the right of having good counsel of na
comes from this
word
as alabi Imabi
he's a great uh
9th century
scholar of hadith from Afghanistan from a place called Bust.
He's a really big from there.
He's a muhad and he's a jurist of the Shaf School, one of the
early
and he
says
about
is a word that you can't really define.
You can't define this word
um because generally the word for suggestion is used in Arabic was
to give a suggestion or
to give some sort of suggestion to somebody.
He
says
that at the core of it
it is
having good will towards someone.
Having a good will.
having goodwill, some sort of good will, like you want good for that person.
And then he
says
that it's not possible to contain this word in one
definition.
But what it really
means
it's
the honey that is derived from a
honeycomb. So
is is the honey the the honey wax.
Do you know honeycomb?
Honeycomb is where honey is what?
Stored. The process of taking honeycomb and
uh removing honey from it.
removing honey from it.
This is
called
it's extrapolating honey from the honeycomb
itself.
So the say
here
it's to be incredibly
incredulously
sincere
to be
sincere. So we already have based on that the condition for giving advice
is sincerity.
So
but now the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says
who's this na to is for
Allah
it's for
he says the first thing is in his book how do you give to Allah
can you give advice God
can you make dua I have some advice for
you
let me tell you how to do your
job
right or
Allah I rather you do something this way than that
Is it permissible to say that?
You can't really give God advice.
So the first type of it means goodwill to God in his book.
Meaning my relationship with Allah is
sincerity. Adherence is called a heart.
It has
uh las with God.
My prayer is done with sincerity.
My fasting is done with sincerity.
We just finished Ramadan a month ago.
What does the prophetam say about Ramadan?
Ramadan. Whoever
fasts,
Ramadan
with faith
and ex
expectancy, Allah forgives them for all of their sins, what they've done in the past, the
future, and the present.
Having expectations of God's goodness
is
to Allah. And then to the book
adherence to the book that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
don't make your houses
graveyards meaning don't make the Quran just something that sits on your shelf it's a decorative
piece you have that big Quran with the beautiful calligraphy you take it on during the
bismillah or the
uh the wedding you do something you know when it h or Ramadan it comes out
but throughout the year it means having some relationship with the book of Allah and adhering
to the law of the Allah tala's book
the principles that come from that book
and to the messenger of Allah sallall alaihi wasallam there's four things the first is knowing
the
sunnah
to the rasool and did the companions givea to the prophet did they give him advice
yes or no or do they just listen
blindly
advice an example of this would be
when Omar was saying he wanted to kill
his cousins. Mhm.
And he got the other person, but he was like, "No, give him off a ransom."
And so
obviously they give him off ransom and then Allah
revealed the following day.
Which which which story are you relating?
Um it was
there's one easy example.
I'll give you an easy example, right?
That's that's
called
like
or you have other verses like that that's different.
What I'm talking about did the companions directly tell the prophet was
rather you do this than this.
Maybe in the battle of the trench the
trench
the trench left the trench.
What happens in the trench?
The prophet the huh asked them for
guidance if he should stay in that post or
well theam
decided to make posts and he said we're going to attack them head on we're going
to make ranks but all the tribes of the Arabs were take attack him from every
direction and what does he ask
is this a command from your lord
does your lord say you have to do this he said no this is what I
thought was a good idea he said then I have a better idea for you
he said let's make a trench
and he builds a trench around the believers to in so so there is no flanking
from any sides of
there's also when the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam comes to
Medina
he walks past a group of companions that are planting date seeds
and they
plant it on one side of the shade such as the practice of the people of
Medina
it's really
important so So the prophet passing says why would you plant plant it on the sage
without the shade?
Why don't you plant it on the other side?
So they removed all of the dates.
They planted it on the other side
and the dates
didn't harvest. And they said, "Yeah, our dates didn't harvest and we listened to you."
He said, "What did I tell you?"
He said, "You planted it on this side, but you told us the I didn't tell
you anything. I just made an observation.
you are have more knowledge of your affairs.
Meaning you don't come to me to micromanage your life.
There are things that I know and there are things that I don't know.
Right? There are things that I know and there are things that you know better than
me.
Every place has its
station. So that's the first that's that's the first thing that there was a relationship.
Now does that mean they degraded the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam?
There was an adab.
There was
an
they were they obeyed God.
They obeyed the messenger of Allah and those that have power over them or authority over
them. There was no there was an adah.
Is this from your lord?
Can I give some advice here?
Can I can I suggest something?
They waited until the messenger of Allah gave them the green light to speak.
They didn't just come and just grab and be like, "Oh, you know your story.
You totally have this wrong."
It was an ad.
And
the sunnah of the prophet wasallam is to have a good will towards Allah in that
if he did
something sallallahu alaihi wasallam there is in it whether you like it or whether I not
like it that's good will there must be good something good about it even if it's
the
or even if it's where he parted his hair there's in that from the big things
the macro to the micro to even how he cut his nails there's and we can't
adhere to every single sunnah it's impossible
But no, you can't degrade a sunnah and say this is a small.
You hear people say this is a small sunnah.
It's not a big sunnah or it's just sunnah.
Have you heard that?
This is this is the opposite of what we're trying to say.
You can't say things like that
because
that having a good opinion
to Allah is not saying things like that.
If he did it, it's a there's lot of good in it.
There's abundant good in it.
And then there is the so you should have a relationship with the And then this
is important. The tone of the rasool sallallahu alaihi wasallam the tone of the prophet what
was his
tone
how did he speak what was his
disposition you'll hear hadith have you guys heard this hadith that there'll be more women in
the hellfire than men
have you heard this before
huh there hadith
is a bonafide hadith
there is no in that hadith
you'll usually
here read that and then say this is a really weird religion and people justify well
technically there's more women on earth
than men
so that means there's probably more women and men now if I study and this is
why it's really important that you take a mosaic a class if you haven't already
if you haven't already or any class but since we're at Mosaic obviously I'm going to
say mosaic a
class
is this an if you if you don't believe in that are you kafir
Why?
Why? You said no, Mars.
You said no.
Why?
That's not one of our like major tenants of our faith.
It's not a tenant of the faith.
The angel is going to ask you, do you believe more women are in the
Then why does the prophet say what is a
tone?
A group of women come to
theoolam and they say and he looks at them in the way that they're behaving and
he
says,
"Oh
you,
oh you group of women."
Did he say, "Oh, all of you women."
He said, "What did he say?
Oh group of you women.
Oh women amongst
women.
You group of women.
I've seen more of you
in the fire than men.
This is
called
this is Arabic grammar that the is or what he's pointing towards is a specific group
within a larger genus of people.
Are you following what I'm saying right now?
It's a specific is it all of them?
It's a specific group.
And they say
why?
He
said
that indeed you
curse each other.
And what kind of curse was it was like oh this that's not how they're talking
to each other.
It wasn't like a reality.
It was not like the Kardashians speak to each other.
They were cursing each other's children.
Oh may your child be born of wedlock.
May your child be a debt.
That's how they used to speak.
These are the type of language if you
readahali or jahali stories this type of language when they talk about cursing
or
they're talking about this when people got angry they used to say may such and such
burn for you may your house they even say this what in Egypt any Egyptians here
mis
no
one mri two masre oh uh what did it say
huh huh
may god destroy your house
so if you're in Cairo and they like you're in the you know somebody cuts you
off they say
right they'll say destroy your house right one of my one of my teachers he would
say
when he's upset you say may god destroy the house of the devil so he makes
it more halal he'll say
they would say may god destroy your house there's something Arabs won't be upset there's something
Arabs Arabs are very intense people
right they love you super super super
super
right they'll say beautiful things to you but when they're angry angry at you.
They'll say some wild stuff to you, right?
They'll say insane
things for you.
And you guys, if you're from Arabs, you know, all of the like Arab curse words
are insane,
right? They're very creative, mashallah.
But they're insane.
They're insane. Some of the stuff is like, "Wow, how did you think of that?"
uh and I won't mention it here because majus inshallah but after we go upstairs I
can tell you
um
so
he saysam
this is what you do and you're ungrateful to the ones that provide for you
you're ungrateful to the ones that provide for you so the tone of the prophet wasallam
is one of goodwill I'm having your back stop doing this
such that you can enter the garden again because I've seen more types of if and
this is for men too like if men do it they But I've seen more of
you types of people.
This is something that you women struggle with.
If you continue to do this, I've seen more type of you in the fire than
the the than other women.
That's the understanding of that hadith,
right? And you could look up
and others, they have an explanation of that of that hadith.
But that's the tone of how the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam spoke.
When he spoke about things that are sometimes even extreme, the tonality of it was one
of goodwill.
was one of good will.
An example of this is bin.
You know
bin
bin was a companion to theul and they were at awar they were at a camp
and outside they were all you know it was a fudger time and they were about
to pray salat and fud
um
and
uh the companions found out recognized that as fudam he prayed in a state of janaba.
Janaba
for
students here was what?
What's
janaba?
What's janaba?
Impurity. Impurity. So if it's if I'm in a state of janaba, I can't pray.
So he was in a what's called is usually technically major ritual impurity.
It usually has major ritual impurity.
And he was in that state.
Um and he prayed and the companion
said
he prayed in that state and it is is it permissible to pray in that state?
It's not permissible.
But he prayed.
So he called Omar.
He said, "What happened?"
He
said,
"It was a cold night.
It was cold at night."
Meaning the water was cold.
You know, the desert's really, really cold.
Like it's heavy cold.
And
he
said
that the water was cold.
I had empathy for myself because I knew I'd probably get sick.
And I remembered the verse in the Quran where Allah
says
that oh you who believe, don't hurt yourselves.
Don't kill yourselves.
God is most compassionate upon you.
So I just made and I prayed.
Is this permissible?
Can you do this?
Yes or no?
What's the prophet's response to this?
You think he said go make your prayer again?
What's his response?
If you were to come to Alim imana
and you told him this, your parents, somebody else, if you told them this, what was
probably the response or you told your mashallah
um
you know your Tik Tok influencer friend
Islam on
on Instagram, if you told them or you told your MSA president board member, what would
they say? No pray.
Huh? Pray again.
You're going to pray again.
You know what the prophet's response was?
The prophet laughed at it, took it lightly, and he never repeated it ever
again.
Like the prophet's like, he clearly knows the ruling.
He clearly knows what he has to do.
Why am I going on rebuking people?
So the prophet's na was not constantly rebuking people, right?
Constantly rebuking people.
Remember I keep talking about the Warner Brothers?
Who are the Warner Brothers?
I say it a
lot.
They're always warning you about stuff.
So they're always whatever you'll somebody will post something uh you you you post a picture
on your Instagram sister.
I just want to give you sound Islamic advice.
The picture you have has one uh somebody's wearing a t-shirt with eyes on it.
So
I would rep you know what I'm saying?
Thank you. It's like mah who made you the
like I never I don't know who you are.
Why are you talking to me?
But
you don't take good advice.
Please humbly like what are you talking about?
Why didn't you humble yourself?
Why are you talking to me?
I don't know who you are.
You're not my dad.
You're not my mom.
Like, you know, you have no you're not my SP.
I have never I don't know.
I don't know anything about you.
How many of us experienced this all the time?
Raise your hand if you experienced this
before,
right? You haven't experienced more.
You've experienced it.
I've seen it.
You've told me.
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
What?
that the that he says in this reality
the thel's
good
is
to have sincerity in your speech in your action
in your sound disposition and in what you're calling towards for good for the sake of
reconciliation between something or fixing something and giving advice to that thing
you have sincerity in your speech, in your action
and in what you are calling towards as the third one is to the hadith says
the imams of the Muslims good counsel for the betterment of the community and sincere advice.
So this is this is a paradigm of advice.
This is how we get advice and it has to go in this
order.
So
I can't get to three if I'm not at one.
So if I'm not doing right by having sincerity to myself and adhering to Allah and
sincerity with God,
then I can't move on to the sunnah
that's your then the sunnah is what I do.
I'm not adhering or having some attempt of adherence to that thing.
If I'm not doing that, then I can move on to giving to my friends, my
family, whatever. Right?
Is this is preventing us to be what they call armchair
critics. You know armchair critics.
They're preventing us from being armchair critics.
Usually what I would argue what I would argue is most people would critique trivial things
but they won't critique big things.
So somebody would
have a wedding a certain way.
We have our own cultural celebrations of weddings whatever or they would um you know
uh have a graduation party or they would have a gathering and there are probably some
trivial matters. Are all gatherings 100% halal?
No.
Right. Not all the time.
There's some things anybody could point out.
Anybody can point out.
Even this mosaic is not 100%.
We could do better here, can we?
We could be more.
We're trying. We're trying.
But we can 100% have more.
Allah bless all the brothers and sisters that have made this place.
We can have more compliance here.
We can have more
serious students of knowledge here.
Can we do that?
Yes or no?
There's nothing wrong with that.
But the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said was known to in
the
he hated trivial
nitpicking nitpicking. Always nitpicking, right?
Like looking for one thing and gotcha.
I got you.
Oh, I'm going to give you advice, right?
He got you for this, brother.
Alhamdulillah, the talk was really good, but you're wearing a chain.
I don't know if the prophet, right?
Subhan Allah. I don't know.
Maybe you should.
Is this all right?
You know what I'm saying?
Is this permissible?
Like can we do that?
Nitpicking small small things here and there.
Um this is something that is
this is something that is
not just something we should avoid but this is
abhorrent. And you look at Im Malik.
When they came to Im Malik
and they would ask him for a
ruling,
his face would start to become
red
and his his his his
uh his
his skin would start to get moist of sweat out of fear.
If I tell this person this thing is haram, then I have to stand in front
of Allah on the day of judgment for my hookum because I'm speaking for Allah and
his messenger. when you're speaking remember when you're speaking about Islamic matters you are speaking on
the pulpit of
Allah
so if he didn't have for something a ruling and he would say is this permissible
he would
say
I dislike it
put a ruling on it but I dislike it I don't like that thing
which is
this is
but if you're seeing something openly haram somebody's openly you know when somebody for some reason
we have a you know we have a brandy bar and
mosaic
then you could come and call
what are you doing you should hold us accountable for higher standards than that
right is that fair to say like why do you guys have this you're teaching Islam
you know what I'm saying why is this over here and not like halal mocktails and
things like that I'm talking about real like hard
liquor
and then Allah tells Bunny is in the Quran
he says
You owe you people.
Do you call people to good
and you forget yourself and you know the book of Allah?
Don't you have any intellect?
Right? And I'll give you this beautiful story.
There's a man named Mo Hassan.
What's my time?
Let me check my time.
Okay. Alhamdulillah. There's a man named Mo Hassan from a place called Yanbour.
You know where Yanbar is?
Yanbu is a coastal city.
Uh
you'll pass to the exit if you've ever been from um Madina to Mecca by bus.
You'll pass Yanbar.
Have you guys been to that train station, the fast train there's a if you go
on the way to that train station, you seen exit says Yanbar.
It's a beautiful coastal city.
It's a factory town now.
But a lot of the alulates the family of
they ended up moving to Yanbar.
Great scholars and
things like that.
And it was word that somebody in the Morocco has Islam.
So the Amida Morocco said there's a group of
Berbers
that need dawa.
They need to learn Islam.
They call his father
and they say, "Uh,
can you send one of an emissary?"
He had three sons, all Adams.
The first son, he says to him, trying to decide which one you should send.
The first one, he says, "When you go there, how shall you judge if you they
don't accept you?
If they don't accept me, I'm going to come back."
He said, "Ah, you're definitely not going."
Second one, he says, "What are you going to do if they don't accept you?"
He said, "Then I'll fight them until they accept me."
He said, "You're not going to go."
Third one, if they accept your message, what if they don't accept you?
What are you going to do?
He said, "I would pray to Hajj every night asking Allah to purify my heart.
Perhaps there's a deficiency in me that they're not affect affecting."
He said, "No, you're the guy."
So, he sends Hass to a place there in his
desert. In fact, he's buried there
and um
he spends about a few years giving dawa, teaching them mashallah this that right, calling them
to Islam. They all become Muslim
and he goes back and his brother is sent he goes back for a break to
visit family and in hisstead his
brother
is is sent to him
and his brother starts to go teach these people and they go to the masjid.
They built a beautiful mosque in the desert and everybody's come.
It's packed. The mjids are packed.
People are coming five times a day.
They're
praying. They're there for the doing that.
People are memorizing, learning Arabic, memorizing all of these good things.
But they're wearing their boots to the
masjid.
They're wearing their boots.
Can you do you wear do we wear do our
boots
say indeed I am Allah?
Remove your shoes.
So how come in the Quran when you meet Allah?
in the house of
Allah
and imagine
I mean forget here like imagine somebody comes to mosaic with their boots on
imagine somebody goes to your masjid and they walk with your boots on what would your
reaction be
would you all eyes on that person right
all
boom and a beline to give that brother who's going to give him na first cuz
m that's what we're good at right beline who's going to call the brother out
so the brother says what type of Islam have you taught them they're here with their
boots on.
So
in response, I got them to come to the masjid.
You get them to take their boots
off.
You can This is a really important part that we want to
we want
we really want to stand for when it comes to especially the work at Mosaic is
recognizing the work of the people that came before us.
They did all of this work building spaces, building communities, building this.
You got me and once you walk in, all you can do is critique that space.
All the work that even this space, how much of work and how many hours built
to create this small humble place in the bottom of a house, it takes a lot
of work, right?
Aid
has to do all of the stuff on the back end.
You have Sharif doing stuff.
Then you have Assal doing having multim meetings.
Then you have Nabiha talking to somebody from a different state.
All this just for this thing.
All of the volunteers, you know, nazu traveling to DC but also being on like all
these different things.
mashallah just so this thing can run
and we can do other things.
Allah grant us
and then you imagine other organizations doing other things and then the masid doing other things.
Then we walk in and it's just like well I'm going to start taking off all
of the negative things here.
Why is this organization like this?
Why isn't there a separator here?
Why do they do it this way?
Why do they do say?
Oh, they're too hardcore.
Yeah, I like them but they all wear traditional clothes and we're a little more modern
so we don't whatever.
This is all from
So what's the what's the remedy for this?
Allah says in the Quran
how
he
says
tell the believers to speak to each other with which that is better.
The devil
wants to cause
dissent
dissent.
And that's why
and I'll get to that
inshallah. So
to have
uh the etiquette of the prophet first embibing the etiquette of the prophet before you give
advice.
So the question is when you see something haram, can I give it like um is
going to give it
like the jah in me is going to come out and give it
like some
like I'm behaving like a non-Muslim like a caffer and nowadays subhan Allah the non-Muslims have
better adab than the Muslims.
We live in a time that non-Muslims have Muhammad Abdu
the the Egyptian.
You guys know Muhammad Abdul
any?
Nobody
knows
Muhammad Abdul
inshallah. But if you're look him up he's a
from from uh he went to France.
They said what did you see?
He
said
over there are some Islam without Muslims and over here I come back I see
Muslims without Islam.
Right? You can unpack that.
That must be a little colonial way of thinking.
But the idea is that
there is Muslims
embibing the
everything the prophet told us not to do and giving advice.
There's an ad to that and then you can give advice to the
believers.
And then he
says,
"What is mandatory for
us
that he said that a believer should only give advice when they have the conditions that
are met, that they're able to do change that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said in
that
maybe you guys are familiar
with
if you see something
evil
change it with your
hand
and if you can't change it with your
tongue
know that it's evil in your faith know that it's evil in your heart and that
is the weakest of faith
that is the weakest so there's something to be say You got to think, am I
going to come to the space and give this person advice and will they listen to
me?
And if they don't, if I can't physically do anything, can I advise them?
And if I don't advise them,
can I
have the interpersonal capital to talk to them?
And if I don't have that,
then should I just know, all right, I'm not I'm not I don't really do that
thing.
Is that something that I'm is that process something that I'm willing to adhere to?
And he says something amazing here.
He
said
that
he
said
if you know that some more harm will come from you approaching that person.
They'll leave Islam.
They'll be pushed away from the religion.
They're not in a good mental space.
They have so many other things going on life and that will push them away.
It is
it is hated by Allah.
It is hated by Allah for you to give that person advice
right now. Do you guys know the Cabba?
Yeah. H yeah.
You know the Cabba.
Good. What shape is the
Cabba?
What shape is the Cabba?
Cube. It's a
cube.
Is that the original shape of the cabba?
What's the original shape?
Exactly. So when you go to the Omrah omrah now is this one place
called
what is that?
That's where it was.
That's where I built it.
And when you're inside the Him,
you're inside the
Cabba.
Do you know why that hasn't been built to its original form?
If that's how Abraham built it, why wouldn't the person put it back to his original
form? You know why he said that?
He said, "Yeah,
if it wasn't for the
newness
of your people to Islam,
I would have broken down this Caba and built it on the foundations of
Ibraimisam." If it wasn't for what's the most sacred place on
earth,
right? Is there if somebody if somebody desecrates the Cabba, how would you feel?
If you open up uh Instagram, there's a thing guardian a Cabba gets desecrated.
How would you feel?
If mosaic gets desecrated, how would you feel?
Bad. How upset would you be?
As how mad if you be if this beautiful thing you this wall has like graffiti
on it with some haram stuff.
I'd be pissed off.
Okay. Would you how would you feel?
Uh disappointed.
Jeez.
That's it.
Disappointed. No.
not
um
how how would you guys feel
how would you feel if somebody came here and they just literally just put like a
bunch of
like
you know waste
they put garbage here and just left huh
hate crime
whatever you'll be upset now imagine the cabba
the cabba
Omar
looked at thea
and said
what
how glorious you are,
how beautiful you are, how majestic you
are
by Allah.
If you were broken
down,
brick by brick,
if you were to be broken down,
the blood of the believer is more sacred in the eyes of Allah than
you.
The belief, the iman of the believer is more sacred than Allah than you.
In order to protect the iman of the new Muslims, the prophet said, "No, no, no.
It's good. Let's protect their faith.
Don't worry about that stuff.
That's all trivial
stuff."
This is called
Call to Allah
with
with insight. This is insight.
Is this thing going to push that person away?
Subhan Allah. Aisha said sallallahu alaihi wasallam that if theam
said that if the first revelation was to be the prohibition of
zena,
alcohol
and reeba, we would all flee a fa flee away from this affair.
Somebody becomes Muslim day one.
They tell him change your name.
No more bacon.
No more this, no more that.
We don't give anybody time to negotiate their relationship with Islam.
And we don't give ourselves time or our peers time to negotiate their relationship with Islam.
This idea that there is no room for sound goodwill.
The brothers just become a man.
He just gone through a lot,
right? You heard somebody a lot.
It was recorded, but whatever.
But
um you find out one of your friends has got like an edible problem.
You don't jump on them.
Hey, did you hear?
I went to his house and I look at closet.
I had to look for something and I found these like edibles.
Bro, is he whatever?
It's like, bro, he's got literally I this is not this person's emmo.
I know them for a minute.
I've known them.
They're good people.
They're standup. They're super strict about the religion.
They pray five times a day.
Something's off here.
there's something that's going on here that's that's pushed them here.
Instead of demonizing them, what you do is like, bro, you just give them time to
negotiate this stuff.
You have a con.
Hey, take them out.
Hey, bro, there's like what are we?
Like, you good?
I just got to be honest.
I was in your house.
I shouldn't have done it.
I saw something, bro.
Are you Is that even And you made assumption.
Maybe that's somebody else's.
Maybe what you make an assumption, have a good opinion, and then if you have good
capital, then you could you could talk to them about
it.
And now there's a protocol for good counsel.
In this surah al
verse number
this is how the prophetam
gives
calls to good and forbids evil.
He says this
is
from the mercy of your lord that you had ease on people.
You were gentle upon them.
If you were
harshed, if your heart was
harsh,
what did Allah say
about?
He
said
their hearts hearts become
hard like rocks.
They don't have any feeling.
They don't have any sensitivity.
sign of the first sign of
the companions that when the the used to say
if we didn't cry
and we thought our hearts became hard and when our hearts became hard we thought we
were turning into
hypocrites cuz we didn't feel for things anymore
so
there was a
there was a suicide in our community a couple years ago Muslim
family
brother was going through some serious issues
uh and he probably you know a good opinion is he he tried to look for
help
but he offed himself he killed himself parents are
comes out of nowhere practicing Muslim
parents
now
the first thing some community members do is they first thing they do
is they say
suicides don't go to Jenna
so we don't pray
jaza
the first thing our community says
it's the first Am
I saying what's the first thought?
We've been conditioned to a spot sometime where people have killed themselves and our response is
their
salvation. So we don't pray over them.
It's a sign of
is it saying that suicide is halal?
Is that what I'm saying?
If that's what you got from
that
is not for
you.
Seeking knowledge maybe is not for you.
But
if
the visal responsible is
like
the response the response is to have some empathetic
concern
for the condition of the parents and of the young boy that has gone through this
that changes everything that means that you're not in a state of
inshallah they would have fled away from you.
So he
says
the first sign of giving good counsel and this means and I'll challenge you to the
broader we're going through uh interesting political frame where people are for one cause another cause
Palestine Israel ICE might this we're going through a lot and there's a lot of stuff
going on
in order for us to speak truth to power and to give to our community and
the broader community we ask ourselves the first thing is we have to
begin by forgiving people.
Why?
A because they're probably not going to listen to you at first.
They're not going to listen to your advice and you're going to be upset.
So before you go there, you go with a clean
heart
that you my my thing is my thing might die, so forgive me.
Um
is there a long wire mess
anywhere?
Um
that you seek forgiveness at night for them.
You should not be giving advice to anybody if you haven't prayed the hajj for them
first.
Nobody you should be giving advice to.
You should not do dawa.
You should not call to Allah if you don't have a routine of the
period. And you're not asking
Allah
forgive my people.
They don't know.
Guide my people they don't know.
My people they actually ask constantly asking forgiveness for
them
and
seek
counsel. Seek
counsel. Go to people and seek counsel.
Have a proper
I died. No.
No. You said so.
I just
have a
um
proper
group of council around you.
that if you
made your decision then
have
so go through this process.
So the process says gentleness and ease and that begins with your social and interpersonal
uh
capital
and
that you begin with good etiquette and good capital
that keeps your heart in check.
And he
says
the first thing is if you give
advice
do so quietly and not
publicly. The first thing
you know call out culture
that's haram. It's fisk.
You don't go online and you call somebody out and say brother but they're doing the
sin publicly. La
first you you
people there. I have it happens to me all the time.
It's like bro you know me.
You have my phone number.
All right.
And we texted 2 days ago.
You were at my house for a part.
Why are you on like why are you tweeting about me?
It happens to all of us.
He
says
to do so quietly and not
openly
sagaciously and not just upright.
Bro, you
stink.
Brother comes to the masjid and they have a little bit of a body odor.
Bo,
you walk up, bro.
You smell so bad.
Look how bad this brother smells.
I mean, that dude, you smell terrible, right?
What? What do you What do you even eat?
Where are you from?
Like
is insane.
But people say stuff like this, do they not?
Right.
And he said that and if they never accept
and never accept your strategy, your gentleness, your your your good counsel, then you could take
like bro, let me tell you something.
I try to be like try to give you gum.
You're like, "No, I'm good, man."
I try to be like, "Dude, you want some Old Spice?
Like, I'm going to wear some.
You put some on like bro, hey, we're going to the masjid.
Let's like put some oud on our celery."
And you're like, "No, bro.
I got to tell you, I've been doing this like for weeks.
I'm going to tell you, don't feel bad.
Bro, but you smell, bro.
Like, I'm trying.
You smell really bad, bro.
Like, I'm telling you, people are just like, dude, I'm trying to like you're trying to
ask for the sister's hand, but you're just like, why is she like, she came close,
she said, and she's like, bro, she just started wearing all of a sudden.
She's not in
generally she's not, but around you, she started wearing.
It's not it's not it's not her, it's you.
It's you, bro.
Right. That that has been like the places like you know what I'm saying?
That's the conversation you can have after just like I'm trying my best to tell the
brother please
something and I know you bro you you drive a Bugatti
there's no reason why like the payments taken away from the colo you know what I'm
saying
like
and then he
says
listen to this
he said have the appropriate conditions met for giving.
If you do not do so, you are an
oppressor. You are not somebody who gives advice.
What's the line between oppression and giving advice?
Um
he says know that when you have been given dominion or you're given the ability to
to to give good counsel you're not hurting the rights
the ama
of your person to not humiliate them
to not degrade them
and this is from
uh
and this is not an intellectual but this is sincere ruling.
This is one that tests your
sincerity. So he says
um the first sign is gentleness ease.
And how does that work is to have
uh to have social and interpersonal capital.
When does the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam given revelation?
revelation not marriage 40
in those 40 years he's known known as
what
huh
when he goes and he gives the
announcement of al-Islam he tells the people if there is an army behind this mountain would
you believe me
they say of course you are
alik
the truthful and the
trustworthy for 40 years Allah
gives him social capital with
people.
He's truthful and he's trustworthy.
He will not tell a lie.
That's why the conditions of prophecy in
if you look at
Im
there's conditions of prophecy of being a prophet.
A
sidd
truthfulness.
Ba
to have
uh
safekeeping,
trustworthiness.
Then
to have intellect, you have to prove that you're somebody of intellect to give da'ah.
This religion is not a religion of idiots.
You have to have some
intellect
for
which you're going out and you're you're not expecting people to just come and
kiss your hand, come to the space, learn Islam, say the
mashallah, how do I do?
You have to go out and talk to people.
You have to have
some
with people. You have to have some uh you have to know people.
You know, you give what one of my mentors call J to the Jamaat.
You're giving Jamaat to the Jamaat, preaching to the
choir. Well, they already know.
If I sit here and tell you all the importance of being Muslim, you'll probably be
like, "Well, I'm we're
here."
So, if you don't have friends and people that you're with that are not Muslim, what
are you doing here?
Allah put you in this country.
So, you have you don't isolate yourself from everybody.
You have a good relation with your neighbors.
You know who your neighbors are that if a new neighbor comes, you bake something, you'll
give it to them.
You welcome them to the neighborhood.
You have an elderly neighborhood.
You knock on their neighbor.
You knock on the door.
Hey, I'm young person.
You're my neighbor.
Listen, if you need anything, give me a call.
Groceries, garbage. Let me know.
Every every I'll take it out.
This is
Islam.
this is da.
All the other stuff is fluff.
This is da.
What can I do for
you
that I can benefit people?
If you're a teacher in the school, you should be the most uh you should be
the the teacher that all the students have so much trust with.
They can come to you with their problems.
You be like a third parent to them.
That's the type of not
dismissive. Oh, there's a bunch of caffer kids.
We don't need to worry about it.
That's how the believer works.
And
then
you're a prophet.
Most of us want to become
before.
There are conditions to the you have to meet those conditions first
and then I can give dawa to people and then I can give sound advice and
then interpersonal capital when the prophet wasallam goes to Abu Bakr and says hey I think
I'm a prophet you know what he says that makes sense
he sounds about right it checks out
yeah you know saying I've seen him
where
most of us
I have this problem a lot outside subhan allah the brother's amazing he gives so much
beautiful dawa
his hadith His mahad of Quran is amazing.
His tajed
and then you go ask brothers that know him really well.
His brother, my brother's here, he's got stories.
Boy, you better keep your mouth
shut.
But they go to his close family members, his parent,
wife,
best friend. Oh, that dude, man, I got stories about him.
It's like, yeah, yeah, I know that version of him, but you don't know the real
dude. The real dude is wild.
Are you
ratchet? Yeah. Yeah, man.
Mashallah, I got some story.
Alhamdulillah, we all have stories.
Um,
but
he says
there's in usually this when they came to the prophet Abu Bakr, it was like he
came was like, "Yeah, I know you so well."
He goes to Khadijah, I think my Allah has abandoned me.
Your lord hasn't abandoned you.
He knows them so well that it's like
what you present inside is far superior than what you present to people outside
that when you speak to their close
people they're like they can vouch for you and be like if you see what he
does outside you have no idea what he does inside
you have no idea the
workhawi you have to know who shikh shahawi is
you know who sharawi is
nobody
sharawi I thought of
Shawiwari.
Alhamdulillah. Uh Shik Shahawi was a great alim, a great scholar and used to give bayan
like this for 10,000
people.
10,000 20,000 people.
Beautiful bayan.
And his son will used to say that one day you know his father he has
a practice. He used to go to the local bathroom.
Somebody took shahada with him.
He used to go to the local bathroom every time he used to give his bayan
and people used to come and call him and mashallah like I'm inspired by your deed
to put pictures of him sign autographs all that all the stuff take selfies and have
selfies by then
um
and he said every Friday
my father used to make me drop him off to this like public park
public toilet there somewhere or whatever I just pick him up later go for a walk
alone just want one time one time I went early and I want to go pick
him up
and it turns off that he was in a janitor's uniform scrubbing the public toilets
bathroom cleaning cleaning the bathrooms with all this dirt on his
and he said Baba what are you doing he goes subhan Allah all these people they
know the good that I've done
they think I'm something I'm reminding myself of my in the eyes of Allah this is
who I really am
I'm just a toilet
cleaner
and he said I remember he said I thank Allah for how many people that he's
guided by my
But I fear on the day of judgment when Allah will present for me through my
bad character. How many of them have left Islam because of me?
How many of them have a hatred for Islam because of me?
Right?
That's forgiveness. Asking God to forgive them and seeking
counsel. And there are two
types of
uh of of
this is
praise
and
deceitful flattery.
So when you're giving a device to people,
you can you should begin by flattering them
first,
but you shouldn't flatter them deceitfully.
Don't put them in a place where they don't belong.
Right? If somebody's like, I have a terrible golf swing, horrible, worst top golf performer you've
ever
ever experienced. I've missed that ball so many times.
But if you tell me, "Hey man, you should mini golf.
I'll kill you all.
But top golf, if there's any energy in it, I can't do it.
And but if you to tell me, Mary, you should really take up
golfing. You're setting me up to humiliate me.
You're not setting me up for
success. You have to praise people for the that Allah has given them and not falsely
praise them, deceitfully praise them.
Because usually it's two people that are pitting against each other like hey you know such
and such got that position you should have it like you're way better how can they
give it to that person can you believe it you should say something and guy goes
oh yeah
for sure you're right what did
when somebody complained about this particular issue he said are you doing
arean
are you the messenger of the devil
are you the messenger ofan and then there is
which is wise flattery
You know, somebody's really, really down.
They don't need your critique right now.
They don't need you to come at them really hard.
Life's been tough on them enough.
They've been going through it.
You do.
You tell them, "Hey, like, chin up, man.
You you're you're really good at what you do.
You know, you're you're a very talented human being.
How can I help you?
This is
mud.
There's a messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam was once as a young boy
as a early Islam and Abu were walking
and they saw a young boy
uh selling
goats
and the prophet really liked this one this goat.
So he said I want that one.
And the young boy
said
this one is not it can't
it can't bear milk.
They can't give
milk.
The prophet was amazed by the truthfulness of this man, this young boy.
So he put the boy and he put his hand on the on the on the
udder of the cow and he started to recite dua and they started to fill up
with milk.
They sort of fill up with milk and he
said,
"What is this?"
And he tells the young boy,
"Oh young
boy."
And he says,
You are a teacher.
This boy is like 10.
He didn't say you're going to become a teacher.
You are a teacher.
I see the
hikma, the wisdom of a teacher in you.
Of somebody that can disseminate knowledge in you.
Let me teach you some words.
And he teaches him this words.
And he empowers this young boy with this ability to give milk, bring back forth milk
from a from aim.
Do you know who this young boy becomes?
Ibnimas
the great muhadith he was able to be like no this person has a skill I'm
going to empower them with this skill
I'm going to give them the
tools
I'm going to give them the the
ability
so
um
there were young people that believed in their lord Allah increased them in
im
So there is
the acceptance of counseling others.
Now
we have to be open as well for people to accept fully
uh accept our counsel.
The first one is counel and critique is not permitted.
The prophet sallallaihi wasallam
said
stop constantly critiquing your brother and sister your community or people.
You will corrupt them.
Everything they do you're like ah this could be better.
H that could be better.
Oh no whatever.
Oh your hijab but here here
I don't know if it counts.
Oh, your beard brother.
Alhamdulillah. You know what I'm saying?
You're this, you know what I'm saying?
Constantly, constantly critique.
They'll be like, "Bro, I'm done, bro.
Like, I'm here."
No. Like, why am I part of this faith?
Why am I part of this lame community?
I come here.
I'm already have bills to pay.
It's a hard time for me to settle down.
I I I'm trying to get to med school or grad school.
I have debt.
I have this.
I have that.
And I come to this community to find uplift and healing.
And all they do is just point flaws on me.
Why am I here?
You will be corrupted.
How many of us have been in a space where you come to you're so like
you're honestly generally scared to be in religious spaces sometimes?
Raise your hand.
You're scared cuz you're like, I don't know what's going to happen here.
We have we're we're so scared that we have the constant critique that women in our
community are preferring to marry non-Muslim men over Muslim men because of the critique and the
not the deficiency in them as Muslim women.
Vice versa, the Muslim men.
That's what we become.
that we're even starting families outside of our faith tradition because of this
because you'll never be good enough to be Muslim enough to be start to start a
family to even get married.
That's that's the situation.
Is this not Am I making this up or am I crazy?
Huh? Okay. Alhamdulillah.
Thank you. Cuz if I was wrong,
boy, I was about to say some stuff that wasn't happening.
Um,
so there's a reality.
We can't be a people that most of the conversation is critiquing the um we sit
down in our dinners and it's critiquing this community, that community.
They don't do this right.
They don't have a space.
Why are you here?
And the second piece is like, bro, who are you?
What have you done for the community?
Where are you in the morning serving the community?
Oh, mah, you know the masjid, bro?
They keep doing fundraising.
What then pay?
So, they want to do fundraising.
You going to pay?
They want to fund raise anymore.
Big
shot.
What you got?
Why? They're doing whatever.
It's like, yeah, the you know the parking.
Well, you're not the 65-year-old uncle doing parking duty.
You're not You're not the uncle doing parking duty.
Oh, the community is whatever.
You're not the aunt who's making biryani at MEC every Friday serving the community.
No, I'm serious.
You look for Yeah, they're right there.
You didn't do it.
Did you do it?
You're not there.
But there was It takes a lot.
Empty vessels make a lot of
noise.
Empty vessels make a lot of noise.
They say a lot of stuff.
It's constant constant critique.
What's the remedy?
Be with people that are around you that you can make sound
with, counsel with.
There's a
saying,
they will never be ruined
who seeks counsel and they will never regret their
choice.
If you know that you have four bonafideed people around you,
a proper
who knows this religion, a proper elder in your community that can give you sound advice
that cares about you,
a brother or sister, your best friend that will not
uh
hold
will will not be able to hold will not hold back just to flatter you.
Um,
and you have a spouse, a somebody who could tell you, speak truth to you, give
you counsel, advice, seek
a good na, and you take it around them, then you do a
you're not going to regret.
You did your due diligence.
You did your due
diligence. So you find a
and
then you seek counsel for people in
that.
Allah says, ask the people of knowledge if you don't know.
You don't go to your if you have diabetes.
You go to your doctor.
You go to the sh for for sound dua.
But you go to your doctor for a remedy,
right? You don't want to come to me ever and just be like, "Hey, I have
a hepatitis. What do I do?"
Go to your doctor.
Why are you talking to me?
I don't know.
I'm not na.
I'm not a doctor.
Naja,
I told you I'm not a This is what
happens. Oh
yeah.
Um
uh
and then you don't go to
the MSA president who's like 19 years old.
Allah blessed them for their work to give you a fatwa.
But she's 19 years old.
They're still milking the kid's breath.
What is he
doing?
But you say like what are you talking about?
19 years old.
I look I swear to God I'm I'm 30
something. I'm 30ome inshallah.
Uh, we don't need to yell out.
It's okay.
But, um,
I promise
you.
Okay. He said 9:15.
That's just
upset.
That's just That's upset.
Look, guys. Look at
Look.
I'll end in
uh
I'm
I'm 30 years old.
I'll tell you,
alhamdulillah, I'm blessed to be with a bunch of teachers.
I started studying Islam at 19,
right? At 19 years old, I graduated program in
27.
The
I asked my teacher who studied double.
I said, when you
graduated, I said, "What did you realize?"
He said, "I realized how much I don't know
about this religion."
I realized how much I don't know about this religion.
So you have
that are
bonafide you have that
are
all right we're done
we're done sorry guys we're done we're
done
and then you have the last thing inshallah
okay
it's amongst the rights of a person to accept advice is
the first thing is don't go fatwa shopping.
So you don't just ask 95 people online Islam Q&A for niha it's not going to
give you na is interpersonal your personal checks and balances if you're part of a community
there should be checks and balances people should check each other
right if something is looks a little gray people are doing things explicitly haram they should
have some level of checks and balances and then the last is be around those that
lift you up but challenge you this is a
someone who guides you to that which saves you from the anger of Allah has interceded
for you.
If you obey them and accept their advice, then their in intercession for you will be
accepted and they will benefit.
We need to intercede for one another in the day of judgment.
As a community collectively, we have to do
we have to have a good will towards one another and call people to good.
If your friend circle is not interceding for you and you realize you're a worse person
because of them, change your friend circle.
And if you realize you are better because of them, then inshallah be somebody that learns
from them and incorporate somebody into a healthy space
and then you make them better by being in your presence.
Alhamdulillah.